the Dead coming back to life sounds
scary but for scientists it can be a
wonderful opportunity of course we're
not talking about zombies rather this
particular opportunity came in the
unlikely form of a large slow-moving
fish called the coelacanth this oddity
dates back 360 million years and was
believed to have died out during the
same mass extinction event that wiped
out the dinosaurs 65 million years ago
two biologists and paleontologists this
creature was a very old and fascinating
but entirely extinct fish forever
fossilized that is until 1938 when
Marjorie Courtney Latimer a curator at a
South African Museum came across a
prehistoric looking gleaming bluefish
hauled up at the nearby docks
she had a hunch that the strange
one-and-a-half meter long specimen was
important but couldn't preserve it in
time to be studied and had it
taxidermied when she finally was able to
reach jlb Smith a local fish expert he
was able to confirm at first sight that
the creature was indeed a coelacanth but
it was another 14 years before a live
specimen was found in the Comoros
Islands allowing scientists to closely
study a creature that had barely evolved
in 300 million years a living fossil
decades later a second species was found
near Indonesia the survival of creatures
thought extinct for so long proved to be
one of the biggest discoveries of the
century but the fact that the coelacanth
came back from the dead isn't all that
makes this fish so astounding even more
intriguing is the fact that genetically
and morphologically the coelacanth has
more in common with four-limbed
vertebrates that almost any other fish
and its smaller genome is ideal for
study
this makes the coelacanth a powerful
link between aquatic and land
vertebrates a living record of their
transition from water to land millions
of years ago the secret to this
transition is in the fins while the
majority of ocean fish fall into the
category of ray-finned fishes
coelacanths are part of a much smaller
evolutionarily distinct group with
thicker fins known as lobe-finned fish
six of the seal against fins contain
bones organized much like our limbs with
one bone connecting the fin to the body
another two connecting the bone to the
tip of the fin and several small finger
like bones at the tip not only are those
fins structured in pairs to move in a
synchronized way the coelacanth even
shares the same genetic sequence that
promotes limb development in land
vertebrates so although the coelacanth
itself isn't a land walker its fins do
resemble those of its close relatives
who first hauled their bodies onto land
with the help of these sturdy flexible
appendages acting is an evolutionary
bridge to the landlubbers that followed
so that's how this prehistoric fish
helps explain the evolutionary movement
to vertebrates from water to land over
millions of years that transition led to
the spread of all four-limbed animals
called tetrapods like amphibians birds
and even the mammals that are our
ancestors there's even another powerful
clue in that unlike most fish selig ants
don't lay eggs instead giving birth to
live young pups just like mammals and
this prehistoric fish will continue to
provide us with fascinating information
about the migration of vertebrates out
of the ocean over 300 million years ago
a journey that ultimately drove our own
evolution survival and existence today
the coelacanth remains a symbol of the
wondrous mysteries that remain to be
uncovered by science with so much left
to learn about this fish the ocean
deaths and evolution itself who knows
what other well-kept secrets our future
discoveries may bring to life